tengo dos números aquí y bueno el número
de arriba tiene 123 escenas y
1 2 3 4 5 unidades el número de abajo
tiene una dos decenas y uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete unidades
entonces dos decenas y siete unidades
ahora lo que yo quiero hacer en este
vídeo es sumar estos dos números 35-27
otra manera de pensarlo es que yo quiero
sumar estos bloques
entonces iniciamos con las unidades ajá
tengo yo cinco unidades aquí
y siete unidades abajo en total bueno
vamos a sumar cinco y siete esos son
doce bloques así que tengo doce bloques
en total aquí serían 8 9 10 11 y 12
bloques muy bien ahora tal vez no te es
un problema aquí porque si yo tomo 5 y 7
y lo sumo obtengo 12 pero bueno yo no
puedo escribir 12 aquí es cierto en el
lugar de las unidades ahí solamente
puedo poner un dígito entonces qué
hacemos lo que podemos hacer es tomar 10
de estos agruparlos
en 10 y ponerlos en el lugar de las
decenas a qué me refiero con esto bueno
podemos tomar 1 2 3 4 5
8 9 y 10 bloques ajá puedo tomar esos 10
bloques agruparlos como como lo están
estas barras y lo pongo en el lugar de
las escenas entonces hagamos eso esto lo
voy a poner aquí
así que bueno lo que hice fue tomar
estos 10 bloques y los re reagrupe en el
lugar de las escenas lo cual a veces se
conoce como cómo cargar entonces cuando
sumas tu cargas números a eso se le
conoce como cargar en lugar de escribir
10 unos lo pongo como una decena y eso
bueno te preguntarás en que nos facilita
la vida bueno es que ahora sólo tengo
dos unidades en el lugar de las unidades
pero tengo otra de escena en lugar de
las decenas ajá y eso se le conoce
algunas personas lo llaman cargar porque
bueno como tú ves aquí estoy sumando 5 y
7 eso me da 12 1 y 2
entonces bueno para ponerlo más claro
entonces tengo 5 + 7 eso es igual a 12 a
12 y como ves el 1 lo puse en las
decenas lo puse arriba y esfuerzo que se
parece parece que lo estás cargando pero
en realidad lo que hiciste fue ponerlo
en el lugar de las escenas solamente
solo recuerda que lo que hicimos fue
decir vía yo tengo cinco unidades y
tengo siete unidades
eso es 12 pero no puedo poner 12 en el
lugar de las unidades entonces tomó 10
de esos 12 hilos reagrupó en 10 luego me
va a sobrar 2 pero una manera sencilla
de ver esto es decir que tenemos 5 y 7
los sumamos eso es 12 y ahora sumamos
las escenas tenemos una dos tres cuatro
cinco seis decenas entonces esas escenas
las pongo aquí abajo ahí está la primera
decena ahí van dos decenas
tengo que tener en total seis escenas
porque eso es la suma total entonces
tres escenas
4 de escenas
5 decenas
ahí van 1 2 3 4 5 decenas falta una
entonces seis decenas uno más tres más
dos es igual a seis
ahí están seis escenas muy bien entonces
bueno tenemos resumiendo uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis escenas más dos
unidades y de este lado tenemos 13 es 4
12 662 6 decenas más 2 unidades
es también 62